klingball ähm unsere Solidarität mit
Israel ist
ungebrochen gilt der Satz nach wie vor
ich finde er gilt und man muss immer
wieder auch
einordnen warum das was wir dort an
grausamen Bildern sehen alles entstanden
ist das war der furchtbare Terrorangriff
der Hamas auf Menschen die an einem
Festival gefeiert haben auf kibozene auf
das friedliche Leben in einer Demokratie
in Israel das ist der Auslöser für alles
das was wir erleben und trotzdem Herr
Lanz will ich ihn auch sagen es es
zerreiß dann ja was man an Bildern sieht
auch aus den palästinensischen Gebieten
die die humanitäre Katastrophe die
zweifels ohne da ist die hohe Zahl der
Toten auch auf der palästinensischen
Seite ich finde dass die Regierung
Netanyahu auch große Fehler macht wenn
man die zwei staatenlösung jetzt in
Frage stellt wenn man sich von der
Perspektive die man für die
palästinensische Seite ja braucht auch
eines eigenen Staates quasi
verabschiedet und man merkt ja auch dass
Israel international